now last night was the Nevada Primary
remember Trump was not on the ballot
he's participating in the caucus
tomorrow that is the voting that
actually counts for RNC delegates not
exactly sure what Nikki Haley's team was
thinking but they opted to participate
in nada's primary despite no delegates
being at stake uh and she's not
participating in the caucus it was
either one or the other uh this is where
things got a little bit weird in
Nevada's primary well voters are allowed
to choose quote none of these candidates
on the ballot that option yesterday
ended up beating Nikki Haley by over 30
points now Nikki hel's home state of
South Carolina is up next now the
question has got to be asked after a
third place finish in Iowa and the
caucus is there double digit loss in New
Hampshire last night's numbers you know
the question is if Nikki Hy doesn't win
her home state what is her path for the
nomination we'll ask her in in a soon to
come interview all right according to
the real Clear Politics average as of
now she is losing to former president
Donald Trump by more than 30 points in
her home state of South Carolina and
speaking of polls we have brand new
Gallup surveys they spell a lot more
trouble for Joe Biden as Democrats now
are struggling with very key
demographics that helped elect him in
2020 look at the surveys conducted
during the entirety of 2023 Democrats
Advantage among non-hispanic black
voters is down to its lowest level since
1999 while the margin with Hispanic
voters is now at its lowest level since
2011 down to just 12 points but it's not
just minority voters that Democrats are
struggling with they're also losing
ground with young voters according to
the Galla poll their advantage with 18
to 29-year-old voters is now just eight
points that's the lowest level since
2005 and while the Democrats and Biden
are struggling in the polls as a whole
perhaps no one has suffered a bigger
polling crisis than your giggling vice
president that's right vice president
Harris who according to a new NBC survey
now has a favorability rating of only
28% compared to 53% who have a negative
view of her and as Democrats continue
sliding in these polls the Supreme Court
they are poised to hear arguments over
the left's attempt to remove Trump from
the ballot in Colorado tomorrow now a
tactic uh that former Obama adviser
David aarod is a lot of things he's not
dumb he called it very disruptive here's
what he said earlier today take a look
there are Myriad legal questions that
they're going to consider tomorrow some
will undoubtedly offer off-ramps if they
want an offramp but I'm trying to
imagine what it would be like if the
Supreme Court said we're removing the
front running uh Republican candidate uh
from the ballot uh and uh and and
essentially saying to the American
people you won't have the opportunity uh
to vote for him and I think it would be
very
very disruptive uh in this country I
think it it will uh create a huge
reaction and that worries
me well should I think anyway in terms
of uh does that for the people that
claim oh democracy is in Peril how
undemocratic meanwhile Biden is refusing
to sit down for a Super Bowl interview
this is now the second year in a row he
has refused to do that after yesterday
maybe it's kind of easy to see why let's
refresh your memories there is some
movement and I don't want to I don't
want
to well maybe choose my words there's
some movement there's been a
response
from the
uh there's been a
response from the
opposition but
um yes I'm sorry from Hamas
oh that's right the terror group is
called Hamas um what about all the
people that were critical when I was one
of the first people to point out this
significant cognitive decline he's still
defending Joe's cognitive State now that
wasn't Biden's only flub of the week you
also made a major slip up when speaking
at a campaign event in Vegas on Sunday
let's refresh your memory on that one
right right after I was elected I went
to what they call a G7 meeting all the
NATO leaders it was in it was in the
south of England and I sat down and I
said America's back and mean from
Germany I mean from France looked at me
and
said uh said you
know what why how long you back
for ask yourself a question have you
ever gone to Walmart Target and a lot of
times they have greeters they tend to be
older people people retired that for
whatever reason maybe they're just bored
they want a little extra cash they meet
you they greet you welcome to Walmart
and then you say how are you can I help
you with anything they're the nicest
most helpful people you'll ever meet in
your life and pleasant and smart I don't
think Joe could be a Walmart greeter
because I don't think he could remember
in a Walmart Superstore whether or not
um where all of the different
departments are I don't think he could
do that job news flash the president uh
Joe Biden a president meeron died in
1996 so unless you're time traveling or
you're speaking to a ghost um you didn't
speak to president meeron no wonder Joe
snubbed the Super Bowl interview now for
the second year in a row the reason is
obvious he is totally incapable of
handling any unscripted interview now
tonight instead of dealing with the
Border crisis Biden is participating all
day in fundraisers in New York City and
stifling traffic there hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else